Tasha: 还有一个手套呢
Tasha: There's another glove.
Tasha: 能拿给我一下吗
Tasha: Can you hand it to me?
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Lucia: 哎这好像不是手套
Lucia: Oh, this doesn't seem to be a glove.
Jake:你小心点啊小心
Jake: Be careful, be careful.
Lucia: sorry是那个厚的是吧
Lucia: Sorry, it's the thick one, right?
Jake: 小心十分小心
Jake: Be very careful.
Jake: 齐的是吧
Jake: It's the same, right?
Tasha: 算了算了
Tasha: Forget it, forget it.
Lucia: 啊找到了
Lucia: Ah, found it.
Tasha: 端 过来了
Tasha: Got it, bring it over.
Jake: 穿过来了
Jake: Brought it over.
Jake: 然后我们这边还有多久
Jake: How much longer do we have here?
Jake: 大概
Jake: Approximately.
Jake: 大概大概还有几分钟呀
Jake: Approximately how many minutes left?
Tasha: 5分钟
Tasha: 5 minutes.
Jake:五分钟好
Jake: Five minutes, okay.
Jake: 哈五分钟之后把这个端上去
Jake: Ha, in five minutes, bring this up.
Jake: 然后上面我直接开了就好
Jake: Then I'll just start it up there.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Okay.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yep, right.
Jake: 然后五分钟我
Jake: In five minutes, I'll...
Jake: 就这基本放视频吧
Jake: Just basically put the video on.
Alice: 要不我拿手套吧
Alice: How about I take the gloves?
Tasha: 能不能直接这种扣过来
Tasha: Can we just clip it over directly?
Alice: 能不能直接这样扣过来可以
Alice: Can we just flip it over like this?
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What should we do?
Lucia: 底下的那个盘子还是要用这个抓吧
Lucia: We still need to use this to grab the plate underneath, right?
Alice: 是
Alice: Yes.
Lucia: 这个嗯也给你带上
Lucia: Here, let me give this to you.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What should we do?
Lucia: 还是两个人一起还是怎么样
Lucia: Should we do it together or what?
Alice:你扣上吧
Alice: You can clip it on.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yay!
Tasha: 呃别太用力
Tasha: Uh, don't use too much force.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
其他人：这个也可以拿了吗
Others: Can we take this one too?
其他人：好哎4盒是吧
Others: Okay, four boxes, right?
其他人：嗯对
Others: Yeah, that's right.
Alice: 有点歪感觉
Alice: Feels a bit crooked.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
其他人：其实应该一个一个拿
Others: Actually, we should take them one by one.
Alice:有点变形
Alice: It's a bit deformed.
Lucia: 小心这个
Lucia: Be careful with this.
Alice:小心烫
Alice: Watch out, it's hot.
Lucia: 这样也挺好的
Lucia: It's fine like this too.
Tasha: 没关系 冷一冷
Tasha: 这个做的一点都不酥
Tasha: This isn't crispy at all.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What should we do?
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Alice:没关系
Alice:弄弄弄粉吧
Alice: Let's add some powder.
Tasha: 我想弄好的
Tasha: I want to make it perfect.
Tasha: 这个自己等会吃掉
Tasha: I'll eat this one later.
Lucia: 呃我等一下我再再撕张纸
Lucia: Uh, wait a moment, I'll tear another piece of paper.
Lucia: 然后把它放到那上面
Lucia: And then put it on top.
Alice: 杨老板下来了吗
Alice: Did Jake come down?
Lucia: 哎呀就这样吧要不
Lucia: Oh well, let's just leave it like this, shall we?
Alice: 这样吧上面进行到什么环节了
Alice: Okay, what's the next step?
Lucia: 要再来一个垫的或者之类的
Lucia: Do we need another pad or something?
Alice: 问答
Alice: Q&A.
Tasha: 123三个口味
Tasha: Three flavors: 1, 2, 3.
Lucia: 这一共多少个
Lucia: How many in total?
Tasha: 123个口味就弄5个
Tasha: Three flavors, let's make five of each.
Alice: 一个弄五个
Alice: Make five of them.
Tasha: 可是摆盘的话5个放不下
Tasha: But if we plate them, five won't fit.
其他人：一盘可以摆几个呀
Others: How many can fit on a plate?
Alice: 最多四个
Alice: At most four.
Lucia: 三四个的样子
Lucia: About three or four.
其他人：三个吧那就
Others: Then let's go with three.
Alice: 抹茶可以少两个
Alice: We can have two less matcha ones.
Alice: 因为那个抹茶不是重了
Alice: Because the matcha ones are heavier.
Alice:但它太热了
Alice: But it's too hot.
Alice:容易化
Alice: They melt easily.
Tasha: 真的化了太热了
Tasha: They really melted, it's too hot.
Tasha: 应该早点做蛋挞
Tasha: We should've made the tarts earlier.
Alice:没事儿 那个鸡蛋 来的太晚了
Alice: It's okay, the eggs came too late.
Lucia: 我们如果把蛋挞放冰箱过一会再下来行不行
Lucia: If we put the tarts in the fridge and take them out later, would that work?
Alice: 放冰箱可能有点潮不过反正它也没有特别脆
Lucia: 就几分
Lucia: Just for a few minutes.
Alice: 磕磕脑袋这个
Alice: Knock your head on this.
Alice:爽
Alice: Feels good.
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: Done.
Tasha: 这粉也太多了
Tasha: This powder is too much.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Alice: 有的人喜欢吃
Alice: Some people like it.
Lucia: 啊对不起没事是哎这个是这个吗哦
Lucia: Ah, sorry, never mind. Hey, is this it? Oh.
Alice: 就是这个就是这个
Alice: Yes, this is it.
Lucia: 没事哎呀这裙子没口袋就麻烦
Lucia: It's nothing. Ah, this dress without pockets is a hassle.
Alice: 我擦一下这个
Alice: Let me wipe this.
Tasha: 等会等会再擦
Tasha: Wait, wait, wipe it later.
Tasha: 等能把那个托盘直接拿过来吗
Tasha: Can you bring the tray over?
其他人：有点小翻车
Alice:没关系，无妨
其他人：刚放完视频
Others: Just finished the video.
Alice: 什么视频
Alice: What video?
Lucia: 什么视频啊
Lucia: What video?
其他人：Wellcome的视频
Others: The Wellcome video.
Alice: 啊我也没看过
Alice: Oh, I haven't seen it either.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
其他人：待会给你们单独放一下
Others: We'll play it for you later.
Tasha: 等等等等
Tasha: Wait, wait, wait.
其他人：就6个这一盘
Others: Just six on this plate.
Alice: 撒豆
Alice: Sprinkle some beans.
其他人：这个是
Others: This is...
其他人：有没有翻车的
Others: Did anyone mess up?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
其他人：我可以试吃一下
Others: Can I try a bite?
Alice: 这个
Alice: This...
Lucia: 这个这个你可
Lucia: This, this, you can...
Alice: 你可以沾点这上面的粉
Alice: You can dip some powder on this.
其他人：这个
Others: This...
Alice: 这两个都是你可沾点
Alice: Both of these, you can dip a bit.
Lucia: 我决定把这个不知道谁点的麦旋风
Lucia: I've decided to claim this McFlurry that no one knows who ordered.
Lucia: 据为己有
Lucia: It's mine now.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我的了啊
Lucia: Hahaha, it's mine!
Lucia: 没事这个是
Lucia: No worries, this is...
Lucia: 其实是昨天晚上有点化
Lucia: Actually, it started melting last night.
Lucia: 然后我们就把它放冰箱了
Lucia: So we put it in the fridge.
Lucia: 然后到现在没有人认领它我的了
Lucia: And now no one has claimed it, so it's mine.
Lucia: 妈呀这画的好夸张啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my, this drawing is so exaggerated, hahaha!
其他人：应该没东西了吧
Others: There should be nothing left, right?
其他人：都上去
Others: Let's go upstairs.
Alice:这个得撒粉呢
Alice: This needs to be sprinkled with powder.
Tasha: 再铺一层纸
Tasha: Lay another layer of paper.
Lucia: 再铺一层纸
Lucia: Lay another layer of paper.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Alice: 还有一个你把那个吃了吧
Alice: There's one more, you can eat that one.
Lucia: 刚这个刚这个撕开的行不行
Lucia: This one, the one just torn, is that okay?
Lucia: 这个比较快一些
Lucia: This one is a bit faster.
Alice:这这这反正 就这样吧
Alice: This, this, anyway, let's just do it this way.
Lucia: 好像不够大
Lucia: Seems like it's not big enough.
Lucia: 是吗还是
Lucia: Is it, or...
Tasha: 好了拿走吧
Tasha: Okay, take it away.
其他人：不是要搁这里搁这上吗
Others: Aren't we supposed to put it here?
Alice: 不是还得撒粉
Alice: Don't we still need to sprinkle powder?
其他人：其实就做几个蛋挞也可以
Others: Actually, just making a few egg tarts is fine.
Tasha: 等等
Tasha: Wait a minute.
Alice: 放点蓝莓吗还是草莓
Alice: Should we add some blueberries or strawberries?
Tasha: 呃这个就不放
Tasha: Uh, let's not add them.
Tasha: 呃放盘托盘对
Tasha: Uh, put it on the tray, yes.
其他人：这4个呃这
Others: These four, uh, these...
Alice:这4个抹茶
Alice: These four matcha ones.
Alice:看能放下不
Alice: See if they can fit.
Lucia: 不行我一只手抓不起来
Lucia: No, I can't pick it up with one hand.
Lucia: 但我另一只手一定要拿啊
Lucia: But I need to hold it with my other hand.
Lucia: 嗯好像确实没有可用的哎
Lucia: Hmm, seems like there really isn't any available.
Alice: 四个
Alice: Four.
Alice: 有点挤
Alice: It's a bit crowded.
其他人：那为什么这样子放三个
Others: Then why put three like this?
其他人：三个放就行
Others: Just put three.
Tasha: 没盘了
Tasha: No more plates.
其他人：不就这几个
Others: Aren't these the few?
其他人：都放这一盘吧
Others: Let's put them all on this plate.
其他人：不要你你先拿
Others: No, you take it first.
Alice: 还有盘吗
Alice: Are there any more plates?
Lucia: 那样那样不好看
Lucia: It doesn't look good like that.
Tasha: 还有盘吗
Tasha: Are there any more plates?
Lucia: 我们还有别的那种那种托盘
Lucia: We have other kinds of trays.
Lucia: 刚那个架子呢
Lucia: Where's that rack from earlier?
Lucia: 在这
Lucia: Here it is.
Alice: 那个架子已经
Alice: That rack is already...
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 那个架子是不是上面也放了东西了
Lucia: Is that rack already holding something?
Lucia: 刚才
Lucia: Just now.
Alice: 抹茶粉在这
Alice: The matcha powder is here.
Alice: 这个给我拽点纸么
Alice: Can you grab me some paper?
Lucia: 你看要多少
Lucia: How much do you need?
Alice: 好好好谢谢
Alice: Okay, okay, thanks.
Alice: 无妨
Alice: No worries.
其他人：草莓还要再切吗
Others: Should we cut more strawberries?
Alice: 不用吃吧
Alice: No, we don't need to eat them.
其他人：不是要放
Others: Aren't we putting them?
其他人：啊你要吃
Others: Oh, you want to eat?
Lucia: 对谢谢
Lucia: Yes, thanks.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
其他人：把这个叶给它摘了
Others: Remove the leaves from this.
Alice: 不不不用摘叶子
Alice: No, no, no need to remove the leaves.
Alice:正着放倒着放还是这样放
Alice: Place it upright, upside down, or like this?
Tasha: 行行行其实倒着放
Tasha: Okay, okay, actually, upside down is fine.
其他人：这咱们可以先放上面然后再你俩吃了
Others: We can put it on top first, then you two can eat it.
其他人：咱们先放上去再然后嗯都行
Others: Let's put it on top first, then, yeah, it's all good.
其他人：这个纸有点丑
Others: This paper looks a bit ugly.
Lucia: 啊已经开始那个什么了吗
Lucia: Ah, has it already started or what?
其他人：马上开始啊
Other people: It's about to start.
Lucia: 那我上去整理一下
Lucia: I'll go up and tidy up.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
其他人：要我帮你拿什么东西
Other people: Want me to help you with anything?
Lucia: 没事没事就稍等一下啊哈哈哈
Lucia: No, no, just wait a bit, haha.
其他人：啊扯到了是吗
Other people: Ah, did it get pulled?
Lucia: 对啊
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 这东西它
Lucia: This thing...
Lucia: 他必须要啊
Lucia: It must be...
Lucia: 嗯好了我把我手机拿上
Lucia: Okay, I got my phone.
Lucia: 然后我先进去整理一下
Lucia: I'll go inside and tidy up first.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈辛辛苦
Lucia: Ah, haha, such hard work.
Lucia: 主持人了
Lucia: Host.
Jake: 我们6个人的眼镜都在哈哈
Jake: All six of our glasses are here, haha.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 我们现在欢迎我们的志愿者Lucia
Jake: Let's welcome our volunteer, Lucia.
Lucia: 谢谢大家
Lucia: Thank you, everyone.
Jake: 哈喽Lucia
Jake: Hello, Lucia.
Lucia: 谢谢大家
Lucia: Thank you, everyone.
Lucia: 我是不是我啥
Lucia: 我要去现在是干嘛啊
Lucia: What am I supposed to do now?
Jake:好呃
Jake: Okay, um...
Lucia: 我我是去收拾还是去怎么样可以啊
Lucia: Should I tidy up or what should I do?
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 对稍微收拾一下然后就稍微收拾一下
Lucia: 啊OK好好好
Lucia: Ah, okay, sure.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure: 那我们先吐会儿
Shure: Then we'll rest for a bit.
Jake: 呃我们还是先QA吧
Jake: Um, let's do a Q&A first.
Jake: 一切都在掌握之中么
Jake: Is everything under control?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 也就是我们
Shure: That means we...
Shure: 今天所有甜点的甜点的厨师
Shure: All the dessert chefs today...
Shure: 然后刚刚在歌词里介绍了一下对
Shure: Were just introduced in the lyrics, yes.
Jake: 对在歌词里介绍
Jake: Yes, introduced in the lyrics.
Jake: 现在是介绍Alice是吧
Jake: Now we're introducing Alice, right?
Jake: 是吧 人呢Alice
Jake: Right? Where is Alice?
Shure: 爱丽丝跑了
Shure: Alice ran off.
Shure: 爱丽丝梦游仙境去啊
Shure: Alice went to Wonderland.
Alice: 啊在这儿呢
Alice: Ah, here I am.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Jake: 好好好好
Jake: Alright, alright, alright
Jake: 介绍介绍完了
Jake: The introduction is done
Jake: 那我们来QA
Jake: Now let's move to the Q&A
Shure: 还是回到QA吧对
Shure: Let's get back to the Q&A, right
Jake: 来进行到QA 2024运动会
Jake: Let's proceed to the Q&A 2024 event
Jake: 那我们
Jake: So we
Jake: 有一个给观众的回答问题时间的环节
Jake: have a segment for answering questions from the audience
Jake: 如果答对抢答的环节
Jake: If you answer correctly in the quick response round
Jake: 抢答对的话就会拿到一个ego币
Jake: If you answer correctly, you'll get an ego coin
Jake: 这个ego币可以用来换取甜品
Jake: This ego coin can be exchanged for desserts
Jake: 和为未来财富自由做准备
Jake: and prepare for future financial freedom
Alice: 还是去后边
Alice: Still go to the back
Jake: 现在现在一个币每一个的价格是
Jake: Now, the current price of each coin is
Jake: 现在是多少钱
Jake: How much is it now?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Jake: 3块人民币
Jake: 3 yuan
Jake: 好嘞现在每个一个币3块人民币
Jake: Okay, now each coin is 3 yuan
Jake: 然后明天明天我们再看看多少钱
Jake: And tomorrow we'll see how much it is
Jake: 那我们第0题
Jake: Now, our first question
Jake: 世界地球日是哪一天
Jake: When is Earth Day?
Jake: 你你举什么手
Jake: Why are you raising your hand?
Shure: 他选择了2B
Shure: He chose 2B
Shure: 2B杨老板
Shure: 2B, Jake
Jake: 我觉得挺对的
Jake: I think that's right
Shure: 你觉得挺对
Shure: You think it's right?
Shure: 那你觉得这题应该值几个一钩币
Shure: Then how many ego coins do you think this question is worth?
Jake:我觉得可能不太值
Jake: I think it's probably not worth much
Jake: 因为他是地0题
Jake: Because it's the first question
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Jake: 啊这是一个热身
Jake: This is just a warm-up
Jake: 来让大家知道怎么举手
Jake: To let everyone know how to raise their hand
Shure: 但是但是
Shure: But but
Shure: 我觉得第一个回答问题的同学
Shure: I think the first student to answer the question
Shure: 勇气可嘉
Shure: is very brave
Shure: 我们应该发出ego币
Shure: We should give them an ego coin
Jake: 来
Jake: Alright
Jake: 领了我们的第一个ego币
Jake: Receive our first ego coin
Shure: 然后下一题
Shure: Now, the next question
Shure: 首次庆祝世界地球日是哪一年
Shure: When was the first Earth Day celebration?
Shure: a 1960年b 1970年c 1980年d 2024年
Shure: a 1960, b 1970, c 1980, d 2024
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Shure: 选b他选择二b
Shure: Choose b, he chose b
Shure: 还有哪位同学有不同意见
Shure: Does anyone else have a different opinion?
Shure: 白毛同学放手
Shure: White-haired classmate, let go
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈勇气可嘉
Jake: Hahahahaha, such courage!
Shure: 他选择的这个日子
Shure: The date he chose
Shure: 就是那种班级倒数第一同学
Shure: is like what the last place student in class would choose
Shure: 看一眼题都不会选的答案
Shure: who wouldn't even look at the question
Shure: 还有还有同学吗
Shure: Any other students?
其他人：我选c
Others: I choose c
Shure: 你选c是吧
Shure: You choose c, right?
Alice: 刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting
Alice: 举手
Alice: Raise your hand
Shure: 看来我们的这个选项非常
Shure: It seems that this option is very
Shure: 的焦灼大家
Shure: competitive among everyone
Shure: 大家难分伯仲
Shure: Everyone is evenly matched
Shure: 只能说那我们公布一下正确答案
Shure: So let's announce the correct answer
Jake: 我查一下哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: I'll check, hahahahaha
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no
Jake: 选B选B哈哈哈哈
Jake: Choose B, choose B, hahahaha
Jake: 选b选b
Jake: Choose b, choose b
Jake: 1970年
Jake: 1970
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed
Shure: 又是这位白衣少年
Shure: It's this boy in white again
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 请
Jake: Please
Shure: 第二题谁是世界地球日的创始人
Shure: Second question, who is the founder of Earth Day?
Shure: a艾尔伯特爱因斯坦b盖盖
Shure: a Albert Einstein, b Guy Guy
其他人：我抢答A
Others: I buzz in, A
Shure: 盖洛德尼德尼尔森c修硕d尚可辛
Shure: Gaylord Nelson, c Shure, d Shang Kexin
Shure: 我我我感觉相机小哥你最你最快
Shure: I feel like the camera guy, you were the fastest
其他人：那要不我看大家都很喜欢B那就B
Others: So, everyone likes B, let's go with B
Shure: 他选择了b
Shure: He chose b
Shure: 还有不同答案吗
Shure: Any other answers?
其他人：众所周知3   所以我选C
Others: As we all know, 3, so I choose C
Shure: 好选择
Shure: Good choice
Shure: 那个白衣少年
Shure: That boy in white
Shure: 那我们想必
Shure: So, we assume
Shure: 大家已经知道
Shure: everyone already knows
Shure: 这个正确答案是什么了吧选择
Shure: So, what's the correct answer then? Choose.
Alice: D
Jake: C
Shure: 选择b其实是啊
Shure: Actually, the correct choice is B.
Jake:唉
Jake: Ugh
Shure: 给大家科普一下
Shure: Let me explain it to everyone.
Shure: 这个盖洛德尼尔森
Shure: This guy, Gaylord Nelson,
Shure: 大家可能不知道他是谁吧
Shure: You might not know who he is.
Shure: 他是这个世界地球日的创始人
Shure: He is the founder of Earth Day.
Shure: 好的那个
Shure: Okay then,
Shure: 这这个题我觉得难度系数非常的大
Shure: I think this question is really hard.
Shure: 需要奖励两个Beats来同学
Shure: We should reward two Beats headphones for this.
Shure: 但鉴于刚刚那个选择d选项的同学
Shure: But considering the person who chose option D,
Shure: 勇气非常可嘉
Shure: Their courage is commendable.
Shure: 我觉得也应该奖励一位
Shure: I think we should reward them too.
Shure: 选c选项那个就是
Shure: Choosing option C is just...
Shure: 就是大聪明
Shure: Really smart.
Shure: 哎呀后面同学把嘴闭上
Shure: Hey, everyone in the back, quiet down.
Jake: 你还有电吗
Jake: Do you still have power?
Shure: 啊第三个
Shure: Ah, the third one.
Shure: 哪个重要的政府机构
Shure: Which important government agency
Shure: 是在第一个世界地球日后成立的
Shure: Was established after the first Earth Day?
Shure: a国家公园管理局b美国农业局c
Shure: A. National Park Service B. Department of Agriculture C.
Shure: 美国环境保护局d
Shure: Environmental Protection Agency D.
Shure: 美国鱼类和野生动物服务局c
Shure: U.S. Fish and Wildlife Service C.
Shure: 选c还有不同答案吗
Shure: Anyone else with a different answer?
Shure: 选最长是吗
Shure: Going with the longest option, right?
Shure: OK选d
Shure: OK, D.
Shure: 还有其他答案吗
Shure: Any other answers?
Shure: 他选了b
Shure: He chose B.
Alice: 选A
Alice: Chose A.
Shure: 你你不要参加回答
Shure: No, you don't get to answer.
Alice: 我不在范围啊
Alice: I'm not part of this?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 要不这位同学你选一下
Shure: How about you, would you like to choose?
Shure: 好公布一下正确答案吧杨老板
Shure: Okay, let's reveal the correct answer, Jake.
Jake: 美国环境保护局
Jake: Environmental Protection Agency.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 我觉得这题也值
Shure: I think this question is also worth it.
Jake: 确实太难了
Jake: It's really too difficult.
其他人：我俩我合俩合资
Others: We both, we jointly invest.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 然后下面第四题
Shure: And now, the fourth question.
Shure: 大约有多少人
Shure: Approximately how many people
Shure: 参加了第一个世界地球日
Shure: participated in the first Earth Day?
Shure: a 30万b 200万c 300人d 2,000万人
Shure: a) 300,000 b) 2,000,000 c) 300 d) 20,000,000
Shure: 他选择了c
Shure: He chose c.
Shure: 这位同学
Shure: This classmate
Shure: 你一直默默无闻
Shure: You have been quiet all along
Shure: 你要不回答一下
Shure: How about you answer?
Shure: 他选第四个
Shure: He chose the fourth one.
Shure: 他们两个选了一个极端
Shure: They both chose an extreme.
Shure: 一个选了300人
Shure: One chose 300 people
Shure: 一个选了2,000万人
Shure: One chose 20,000,000 people
Shure: 还有不同答案吗
Shure: Any different answers?
Shure: 你看看这个头脑
Shure: Look at this brain.
Shure: 中庸之道对
Shure: The middle way, right.
Shure: 选择了对冲
Shure: Chose to hedge
Shure: 选择了30万还有吗
Shure: Chose 300,000, any more?
其他人：有没有人是对的
Others: Is anyone correct?
Shure: 对公布答案
Shure: Yes, let's reveal the answer.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake
Shure: 2,000万人
Shure: 20,000,000 people
Shure: 没有想到吧
Shure: Didn't expect that, right?
Shure: 就是说明这个日子非常重要
Shure: This shows how important this day is.
Shure: 第一次办就有这么多人参加
Shure: So many people participated in the first event.
Shure: 哪哪位同学选择2,000万来着
Shure: Which student chose 20,000,000?
Shure: 白衣小哥这个
Shure: The guy in the white shirt.
Shure: 这个问题两个币子
Shure: For this question, two tokens.
Jake: 这个可以稍作科普
Jake: This can be briefly explained.
Jake: 因为这个世界地球日
Jake: Because Earth Day
Jake: 它主要在高校之间
Jake: Mainly takes place in universities.
Jake: 高校内进行
Jake: Within universities.
Jake: 然后高校的那帮人
Jake: And the people in universities
Jake: 然后高校的那帮人对都搞得进去
Jake: And the people in universities are all involved.
Jake: 都搞得进去
Jake: All involved.
Shure: 所以我们有2,000万人参加
Shure: So we had 20,000,000 participants.
Jake: 里边是最最重要的一个活动
Jake: It was the most important event inside.
Shure: 好的下一题
Shure: Alright, next question.
Shure: 今年的世界地球日的主题是什么
Shure: What's the theme for this year's Earth Day?
Shure: a投资我们的星球
Shure: a) Invest in Our Planet
Shure: b动员地球
Shure: b) Mobilize the Earth
Shure: c星球对抗塑料d 10亿绿色行动
Shure: c) Planet vs. Plastic d) Billion Acts of Green
Shure: 请抢答
Shure: Buzz in to answer!
Shure: 还有不同答案吗
Shure: Any other answers?
Shure: 好的BD
Shure: Alright, B and D.
Shure: 公布正确答案
Shure: Let's reveal the correct answer.
Jake:c
Jake: c)
Shure: CC选项今年的主题叫做planet versus plastic
Shure: Correct! The theme this year is "Planet vs. Plastic."
Shure: 就是星球对抗塑料
Shure: That's "Planet vs. Plastic."
Shure: 是我们今年的世界进球日的主题
Shure: It’s the theme for this year's Earth Day.
Shure: 然后恭喜
Shure: Congratulations!
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 好问题
Jake: Good question.
Jake: 我们也不知道
Jake: We didn’t know either.
Shure: 不不
Shure: No, no.
其他人：这显像是生造出来的还是
Others: Is this made up or...
Shure: 不这个
Shure: No, this...
Jake: 这所有的题目都是几比几十
Jake: All these questions are ratios of some sort.
Shure: 但是答案保真的这个是
Shure: But the answers are guaranteed to be correct.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 啊没有没有这个
Shure: Ah, no, no, not this one.
Shure: 其他确实是都没有
Shure: The others indeed aren't.
Shure: 没有出现过的都是胡搜出来的
Shure: The ones that haven't appeared are just made up.
Shure: 然后这题三个币子
Shure: And this question, three coins.
Shure: 这怎么还有分尾组呢
Shure: Why is there still a sub-group?
Lucia: 哈哈哈下哎
Lucia: Hahaha, next!
Shure: 下
Shure: Next.
Shure: 下一题第7题
Shure: Next question, number 7.
Shure: 地球的南极冰啊
Shure: The ice of Earth's South Pole.
Shure: 地球的南极冰盖
Shure: The ice cap of Earth's South Pole.
Shure: 锁定了多少比百分比的淡水
Shure: How much percentage of freshwater does it lock?
Shure: a大约50%
Shure: a) About 50%
Shure: b大约70% c大约90% d大约30%
Shure: b) About 70% c) About 90% d) About 30%
Shure: C2B
Shure: C to B.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 早上好
Jake: Good morning.
Lucia: 早上好
Lucia: Good morning
Lucia: 起床了
Lucia: Time to get up
Shure: 好那没有其他的选项了
Shure: Okay, then there are no other options
Shure: 公布答案杨老板 90%
Shure: Announcing the answer, Jake, 90%
Lucia: 紫糖呢我需要我的冰淇淋
Lucia: What about Violet, I need my ice cream
Shure: 我们其实世界呃
Shure: Actually, our world, uh
Lucia: 哦在那边去找他
Lucia: Oh, he's over there, go find him
Shure: 就是地球上最大的淡水资源
Shure: The largest freshwater resource on Earth
Shure: 都是南极冰盖锁定的
Shure: is locked in the Antarctic ice sheet
Shure: 对所以是90%
Shure: Yes, so it's 90%
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Shure: 然后这题也三个例子吧
Shure: And this question has three examples
Lucia: 我需要我的冰淇淋
Lucia: I need my ice cream
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Alice: 提问冰盖跟奶盖什么意
Alice: Question, what's the connection between ice sheet and cream cap
Alice: 什么关系
Alice: What's the relationship
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Shure: 呃好问题
Shure: Uh, good question
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay
Shure: 就是在我说说你听听
Shure: So, let me tell you
Shure: 在想当初大约3,500万年前
Shure: Thinking back to about 35 million years ago
Lucia: 有50%的字是一样的
Lucia: 50% of the words are the same
Shure: 继女娲补天的时候
Shure: After Nuwa mended the sky
Lucia: 哎我还是坐这边吧
Lucia: Hey, I'll sit here instead
Shure: 创造了一个双胞胎
Shure: Created a pair of twins
Lucia: 是不是会挡啊
Lucia: Am I blocking?
Shure: 一个叫冰盖
Shure: One called ice sheet
Lucia: 对不起对不起
Lucia: Sorry, sorry
Shure: 一个叫奶盖
Shure: One called cream cap
Shure: 对大概就是这么回事您说
Shure: That's roughly the story, you see
Lucia: 本来想坐那
Lucia: Originally wanted to sit there
其他人：我有一个问题
Others: I have a question
Lucia: 但是感觉坐那好像会挡住后面的嘉宾
Lucia: But it seems like sitting there would block the guests behind
其他人：在我印象里它的淡水占72%,但是冰盖是90%
Others: In my impression, its freshwater is 72%, but the ice sheet is 90%
Lucia: 要不然还是坐这吧
Lucia: Maybe I'll just sit here
其他人：但你这个问是它储存多少淡水而是冰盖有多少水
Others: But your question is about how much freshwater it stores, not how much water the ice sheet has
其他人：所以你check一下
Others: So you should check it
Shure: 不是
Shure: No
Shure: 他是就是占占了全球淡水的多少
Shure: It's about how much of the world's freshwater it contains
其他人：但是你这个是淡水，90%只是却不是淡水
Others: But you were talking about freshwater, 90% is just not freshwater
其他人：你可以看一下有没有那个搜一下
Others: Can you check if there is... search it up.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh my!
Shure: 有人提出了challenge
Shure: Someone has issued a challenge.
Shure: 杨老板南极波盖
Shure: Jake, the Antarctic ice cap.
其他人：已超过这个14后面
Others: Exceeds 14 behind this.
其他人：后面六个零平方公里
Others: Behind it, six zeros square kilometers.
其他人：厚度达到4公里以上所含的冰量
Others: The thickness reaches more than 4 kilometers, the ice volume contained.
其他人：庞大相当于地球所有淡水水量
Others: It's vast, equivalent to all of Earth's freshwater.
其他人： 的约70%
Others: About 70%.
Lucia: 嗯啊
Lucia: Hmm, ah.
Lucia: 嗯退退
Lucia: Hmm, back off.
其他人：啊
Others: Ah.
Shure: 那水有70%啊
Shure: That's 70% of the water.
Shure: 30% 然后这个水的70%的水里面
Shure: 30%, and then of that 70% of water...
Shure: 有90%的水是在南极冰盖
Shure: 90% of the water is in the Antarctic ice cap.
Katrina: 好不符合我们这几片基调啊
Katrina: This doesn't match our tone at all.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 大家好认真哈哈哈
Lucia: Everyone is so serious, hahaha.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Lucia: 没想到哈哈哈
Lucia: Didn't expect that, hahaha.
Shure: 是的那
Shure: Yes, so...
Alice:对因为有的水不是淡水
Alice: Yes, because some water isn't freshwater.
Lucia: 原来只有我们在弱智版
Lucia: Turns out we're the only ones in the dumb version.
Shure: 转移一下资产
Shure: Transfer some assets.
其他人：但我们确定哪 三个是原来的
Others: But we're sure which three are the original.
其他人：好随便给你什么
Others: Fine, just give you something.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 然后那我们再奖励一枚币子给
Shure: Then we'll reward a coin to...
Shure: 查出正确答案的同学
Shure: The student who finds the correct answer.
Shure: 非常好
Shure: Very good.
Shure: 那么下一题
Shure: Now the next question.
Shure: 地球的南极
Shure: Earth's Antarctic.
其他人：哎哎
Others: Hey, hey.
Shure: 他让我梅开二度的难堪
Shure: It made me awkward twice.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 从太阳到地球
Shure: From the sun to the Earth.
Shure: 阳光需要多长时间到达
Shure: How long does sunlight take to reach?
Shure: 这个
Shure: This...
Shure: 其实是我们好像高中那种经常算的
Shure: Actually, we used to calculate this often in high school.
Shure: 哎呦已经有两位同学举手了
Shure: Oh, two students have already raised their hands.
Shure: 8分19秒
Shure: 8 minutes 19 seconds
Shure: 哎我其实你们两个同时举手
Shure: Hey, actually, both of you raised your hands at the same time
Shure: 那你们还有其他答案吗
Shure: Do you have any other answers?
其他人：我选B
Others: I choose B
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 你选D20前
Shure: You chose D before 20
其他人：啊
Others: Ah
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 你知道这个地意味着什么意思吗
Shure: Do you know what this means?
Shure: 就是我们的表转了20圈
Shure: It means our clock turned 20 times
Shure: 才有一天会看到太阳
Shure: Before we see the sun in a day
Lucia: 太哈哈哈哈
Lucia: That's so funny hahaha
Alice: 确保一定有一个正确答案
Alice: Make sure there's always a correct answer
Alice: 为我们的顺利进行
Alice: For our smooth progress
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah ah ah
Shure: 这这位同学纠正了我的
Shure: This student corrected my
Shure: 我的错误
Shure: My mistake
Shure: 是表转了40圈
Shure: It's 40 turns of the clock
Shure: 是20圈啊
Shure: It's 20 turns
Shure: 对对对我舒服了
Shure: Right, right, I feel better now
Shure: 哎正确答案就谁
Shure: Hey, who got the correct answer?
Shure: 是吧对
Shure: Is it right?
Shure: 是8分19秒
Shure: It's 8 minutes 19 seconds
Shure: 大家还记得那个怎么算的吗
Shure: Do you all remember how to calculate that?
其他人：谁问你了
Others: Who asked you?
其他人：距离除以光速
Others: Distance divided by speed of light
Shure: 是是就其实就是这么简单对
Shure: Yes, yes, it's actually that simple
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
其他人：是这样的
Others: That's right
其他人：所以如果真的需要海天的话
Others: So if we really need the ocean and sky
其他人：那那南极冰盖肯定不会占地球的
Others: Then the Antarctic ice cap surely won't cover the Earth
其他人：占水70% 那起码太阳没了
Others: Covering 70% of water, at least the sun won't be gone
Katrina: 太阳没了地球还能二然太阳
Katrina: If the sun is gone, Earth can still have another sun
Lucia: 但问题太阳是持续发光
Lucia: But the sun continuously shines
Lucia: 他又不是唰一下然后又熄灭
Lucia: It's not like it suddenly flashes and then goes out
Shure: 你们你们2位
Shure: You two
Shure: 每人两个
Shure: Each has two
其他人： 一方面感谢的是这个样子的话如果太阳坏掉了的话
Others: On one hand, thanks to it, if the sun breaks down
其他人： 也还能
Others: We can still...
Lucia: 你还能再活20天哈哈哈
Lucia: You can still live for another 20 days hahaha
Shure: 很乐观
Shure: Very optimistic.
其他人： 我先看 了8分钟之前
Others: I watched the last 8 minutes first.
Lucia: 太阳冷却了
Lucia: The sun has cooled down.
Lucia: 我们还能再活20天
Lucia: We can live for another 20 days.
Katrina: 哈哈别把谢冰茹搞蒙了哈
Katrina: Haha, don't confuse Xie Bingru.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 下一个问题
Shure: Next question.
Lucia: 哈哈哈神经病
Lucia: Hahaha, crazy.
Shure: 陨石
Shure: Meteorite.
Shure: 为什么每次都能精准的砸到陨石坑
Shure: Why does it always hit the crater precisely?
Lucia: 谁把这个问题加进去了
Lucia: Who added this question?
Lucia: 哈哈哈这个问题哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha, this question, hahaha.
其他人：谁问的这个问题
Others: Who asked this question?
Shure: 这是一个开放性问题
Shure: This is an open-ended question.
Shure: 根据你们的回答
Shure: Based on your answers,
Shure: 我进行判断
Shure: I will make a judgment.
Shure: 给你们发币
Shure: And give you tokens.
Lucia: 好好好
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Shure: 这个每人都来回答一下来
Shure: Everyone should answer this one.
其他人：我觉得
Others: I think
其他人：这可以转化成一个前述范式的问题
Others: This can be turned into a prior paradigm question.
其他人：就是它这个因果的问题
Others: It's about causality.
其他人：就是有隐之坑
Others: There is a hidden crater.
其他人：这是一个前置命题
Others: It's a prepositional argument.
其他人：然后它可以导致后面的问题
Others: And it can lead to subsequent questions.
其他人：那么如果前面问题是1的话
Others: So if the previous question is 1,
其他人：后面的问题肯定是一个有陨石坑
Others: The following question must have a crater.
Shure: 所以说肯定有陨石
Shure: So, there must be a meteorite.
Shure: 但如果前面那个没有陨石坑的话
Shure: But if the previous one doesn't have a crater,
Shure: 它这个这个
Shure: This, this,
Shure: 这个病题始终是真的
Shure: This proposition is always true.
Tasha: 他已经得满分了
Tasha: He already got full marks.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
其他人：虽然很想同意这个话
Others: Although I really want to agree with this,
其他人：但是呢还
Others: But still...
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
其他人：陨石坑为什么一定要有陨石
Others: Why does a crater have to have a meteorite?
Shure: 反方辩手
Shure: Opposing debater.
Lucia: 反方面说
Lucia: The opposing side says...
其他人：因为我觉得老婆饼里没有给他老婆没有明确的
其他人：明事的一个
Others: Made it clear.
其他人：谁造成谁的
Others: Who caused what.
其他人：但是陨石坑是由陨石造成的
Others: But craters are caused by meteorites.
Lucia: 你不能说是老婆饼是由老婆造成的
Lucia: You can't say a wife's cake is made by a wife.
Tasha: 我们俩至少跟他不在一条线上
Tasha: At least we're not on the same page as him.
其他人：哦有一个
Others: Oh, there's one.
其他人：这样的一个哦
Others: There’s one like that.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 那我们宣判反方一
Shure: Then we declare the opposition side one.
Shure: 正方一辩赢了
Shure: The affirmative side wins.
Shure: 好你先思考然后
Shure: Okay, you think about it first and then...
Katrina: 我觉得是因为陨石自带GPS系统
Katrina: I think it's because meteorites have GPS systems.
Katrina: 他肯定能精确定位到陨石
Katrina: They can definitely pinpoint the location of the meteorite.
Katrina: 对不对有没有道理
Katrina: Right? Does that make sense?
Shure: 我觉得她说这个也不无道理
Shure: I think what she said makes sense too.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 来来，说一下
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
其他人：老师好老师
Others: Hello teacher.
Shure: 你好害羞啊哈哈
Shure: You're so shy, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 你有你有想到什么反例来反驳他吗
Shure: Do you have any counterexamples to refute him?
Alice: 这题选C
Alice: Choose C for this question.
Lucia: 没有选项
Shure: 选c选项的同学也是非常的有个性
Shure: Choosing the C option shows a lot of personality.
Shure: 好吧好吧
Shure: Alright, alright.
Lucia: 哈哈你的形体
Lucia: Haha, your posture.
Shure: 那这个问题我决定二二二
Shure: For this question, I decide two-two-two.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 二二给大家每人发两ego币好吧
Shure: I'll give everyone two ego coins, okay?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina: 笑死
Katrina: So funny.
Shure: 下一个问题
Shure: Next question.
Shure: 吃止痛药打架算开挂吗
Shure: Does taking painkillers in a fight count as cheating?
Lucia: 这跟地球人都没关系啦
Lucia: This has nothing to do with earthlings.
其他人：文明人干的事，怎么叫开挂
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 已经有同学发现了盲点哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Someone already spotted the blind spot, hahaha.
Alice: 是我们从弱智吧找的问题
Alice: We found this question from Idiot 8.
其他人：上一个也是吗
Alice: 是
Alice: Yes
Lucia: 明显哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Obviously, hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：像一个这种东西
Others: Looks like one of those things
其他人：一看就是中文高质量语料不行的是吧
Others: Clearly, high-quality Chinese corpus isn't working, right?
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 这种大家换一个问题吧
Shure: Let's change the question, everyone
Jake: 哈没有更多了
Jake: Haha, there's no more
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 但是最后有一个问题啊
Jake: But there's one last question
其他人：也不是说不可以
Others: Not that it's impossible
其他人：可以补背门夹不能打
Others: You can back out, but can't hit
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Shure: 他的答案非常的好
Shure: His answer is really good
Lucia: 相似相融哈哈哈
Lucia: Similar and merged, hahaha
Shure: 必须再奖励一个
Shure: He deserves another reward
Shure: 现在收获非常颇丰
Shure: We have gained a lot now
Shure: 再下一个吧
Shure: Next one, please
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 不孕不育会遗传吗
Shure: Is infertility hereditary?
Shure: 大家觉得
Shure: What do you all think?
其他人：试管说试管代孕的方法
Others: Talking about test tube and surrogacy methods
Alice: 这是不是要被逼了
Alice: Are we being forced here?
Shure: 你看二位二位学者
Shure: Look at the two scholars here
Lucia: 啊植物的三倍体是吧
Lucia: Ah, triploids in plants, right?
Shure: 来来来这个是
Shure: Come on, this is
其他人：还有一个问题
Others: There's one more question
Shure: 那这个是什么
Shure: So what is this?
Jake: 之前
Jake: Earlier
Jake: 到第14题中间有一个
Jake: In the middle of question 14, there was one
Jake: 其实只有13题对
Jake: Actually, there were only 13 questions, right
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Shure: 对刚刚有一个题号
Alice:哦 对
Alice: Oh, right
Shure: 没有大家有发现吗
Shure: Didn't anyone notice?
Shure: 这是一个彩蛋问题
Shure: This is an Easter egg question
Shure: 这个是一个5分的问题
Shure: This is a 5-point question
其他人：隐藏问题
Others: Hidden question
Shure: 这是一个数
其他人：C
Others: C
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈这是一个数
Lucia: Hahaha, it's a number
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
其他人：那那个重复的是什么题
Others: So what was the repeated question?
Shure: 重复的就是为了迷惑你
Shure: The repeated one was to confuse you
Shure: 所以他遗漏了啊
Shure: So he missed it
Shure: 那重复的不算
Shure: The repeated ones don't count
Shure: 那个遗漏了哪
Shure: Which one did he miss?
Shure: 哪个题号
Shure: 大家有注意到吗
Shure: Did anyone notice?
其他人：0-13题
Others: Questions 0-13
其他人：7
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Shure: 啊 0-13对
Shure: Ah, 0-13, right
Shure: 0-13他他说7
Shure: He said 7 for 0-13
Tasha: 这是什么说出来
Tasha: What is this? Say it out loud
Lucia: 九随便说九
Lucia: Nine, just say nine
Shure: 9
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Shure: 这这这位同学呢
Shure: This, this, this classmate
其他人：要猜一个没有的数字啊
Others: Guess a number that's not there
其他人：对99 哈哈哈他猜过了7他猜过了9
Others: Right, 99. Hahaha, he guessed 7, he guessed 9
Shure: 他猜过了7
Shure: He guessed 7
Shure: 他猜过了9
Shure: He guessed 9
Shure: 他猜过了12
Shure: He guessed 12
其他人：0-13对0-13
Others: 0-13, right, 0-13
Shure: 对 0-13里面
Shure: Right, within 0-13
Shure: 13就是上一题哈哈
Shure: 13 was the last episode, haha
Jake:看来会赢
Jake: Looks like we're going to win
Alice: 老师这种难题
Alice: Teacher, this kind of tough question
Alice: 我们家刘婷就不参加了
Alice: Our Liu Ting won't participate
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Shure: 猜一个吧
Shure: Just guess one
Shure: 十十难难道要要遗落了吗
Shure: Ten, ten, hard, is it going to be missed?
Shure: 这个给大家缩小一下范围
Shure: Let me narrow it down a bit for you all
其他人：5
Others: 5
Shure: 在啊这个数它不是一个质数
Shure: This number, it isn't a prime number
Lucia:  4
Lucia: 4
其他人：  4
Others: 4
Shure: 8你
Shure: 8 you
Shure: 继续 12
Shure: Continue, 12
Tasha: 11
Lucia: 6
Shure: 7是质数
Shure: 7 is a prime number
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 到底在说什么东西
Tasha: What are you guys even talking about?
Shure: 5也是质数
Shure: 5 is also a prime number
Tasha: 为什么我能精准的命中这些东西
Tasha: Why am I hitting these numbers so precisely?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
其他人：哎呀已经排除掉一大半了
Others: Oh man, we've already ruled out more than half
Tasha: 你们在说什么
Tasha: What are you talking about?
其他人：二三五七1113都不15
Others: 2, 3, 5, 7, 11, 13, but not 15
其他人：没剩几个了
Others: There aren't many left
Alice: 5是质数哈哈哈哈
Alice: 5 is a prime number, hahaha
Shure: 5是指数哈
Shure: 5 is a prime number, haha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
其他人：7年没学过数学了
Others: Haven't studied math in 7 years
Shure: 哈行
Shure: Haha, alright
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 他坚持是5
Shure: He insists it's 5
Shure: 那我们也没有办法
Shure: Well, we can't do anything about that
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 您您8
Shure: You, you, 8
其他人：不是质数 还是是质敉
Others: Not a prime number, or is it a prime number?
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 不是质数
Shure: 猜一个猜一个猜一个猜一个
Shure: Guess one, guess one, guess one, guess one
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Shure: 给面给面给面
Shure: Give face, give face, give face
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha: 合理啊
Tasha: Makes sense
Shure: 他给我面子
Shure: He's giving me face.
Shure: 我的室友们他给我面子
Shure: My roommates, he's giving me face.
Shure: 好吧好吧那
Shure: Alright, alright, then...
Jake: 翻翻呗
Jake: Flip it over.
Shure: 我我记住了是6
Shure: I remember, it's 6.
Alice: 没人猜啊
Alice: No one guessed?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Shure: 所以没人猜
Shure: So no one guessed.
Jake: 确实没人猜啊
Jake: Yeah, no one guessed.
Shure: 所以所以我们这个大奖只能流掉
Alice:能均分吗，哈哈哈
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 是几
Jake: 6
Jake: 6.
Alice: 6
Alice: 6.
Shure: 6
Shure: 6.
Jake: 6
Jake: 6.
Tasha: 不是有人猜了
Tasha: But someone did guess.
Jake: 确实一个人都没猜到99倒是有人猜
Jake: Yeah, no one guessed it, but someone did guess 99.
其他人：给我5个吧
Others: Give me 5.
Shure: 那
Shure: Then...
Shure: 我们其实就应该到我们的action time了
Shure: We should actually move to our action time.
Shure: 就我们的拍卖时间
Shure: Let's start our auction time.
Shure: 那我们先有请我们的host
Shure: So let's first welcome our host.
Shure: 我们的这房间的主人们
Shure: The owners of this room.
Shure: 先来拍一拍东西
Shure: To come up and auction something.
Shure: 来掌声有请第一位
Shure: Let's give a round of applause for the first one.
Alice: 不是我还没拿
Alice: Wait, I haven't got mine yet.
Jake: 我们我们先统计一下币
Jake: Let's count our coins first.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 大家手上都有多少币
Shure: How many coins does everyone have?
Katrina: 有几个了
Katrina: How many do we have?
Tasha: 不是
Tasha: No...
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:呵呵呵
Alice: Hehehe.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 问一下吧
Tasha: Ask first.
Katrina: 哈哈哈被劈一下
Katrina: Hahaha, got zapped.
Tasha: 那还邀请
Tasha: Then still invite...
Lucia: 我是不是也得把我的小狗接上来
Lucia: Should I bring my puppy up too?
Alice: 你不是有那个水母灯吗
Alice: Don't you have that jellyfish lamp?
Katrina: 你们俩一人一只小狗吗
Katrina: Do you both have a puppy each?
Lucia: 水母没有灯珠
Lucia: The jellyfish doesn't have a light bulb.
Lucia: 他现在不是灯
Lucia: It's not a lamp right now.
Lucia: 他只是水母
Lucia: It's just a jellyfish.
Alice: 那把狗请上来
Alice: Then bring up the dog.
Lucia: 哈哈行
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Lucia: 我去请狗了
Lucia: I'll go get the dog.
其他人：使用范围有限
Others: Limited usage range.
Katrina: 刚静静叠了个被子哈哈哈
Katrina: Just now, Jingjing folded a blanket, haha.
Tasha: 对啊没有没有没有
Tasha: Yeah, no, no, no.
Lucia: shit啊没事
Lucia: Shit, it's okay.
Lucia: 我想把它弄结实点
Lucia: I wanted to make it sturdier.
Lucia: 然后它掉
Lucia: And then it fell.
其他人：那上面已经开始拍卖了
Others: The auction has already started.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah, it has.
Lucia: 来吧你赶上
Lucia: Come on, you made it.
Lucia: 赶上了精彩环节
Lucia: You made it for the exciting part.
Lucia: 不过你错过了弱智巴题目
Lucia: But you missed the dumb questions.
其他人：啊这
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice: 你就大L吧
Alice: You're just Big L.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Tasha: 呃呃
Tasha: Uh, uh.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 到哪了
Lucia: Where were we?
其他人：我坐我坐
Others: I'm sitting, I'm sitting.
其他人：我的小马啊
Others: My little pony.
Lucia: 行行谢谢你
Lucia: Okay, okay, thank you.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
其他人： 智性恋嗯多丑都行
Others: Sapiosexual, any looks are fine.
Lucia: 那你倒着哈哈
Lucia: Then you go backwards, haha.
其他人： 是这样子
Others: It's like this.
Tasha: 知道什么叫智性恋吗
Tasha:  JK JK是什么啊
Tasha: JK, what does JK mean?
Tasha: 啊JK智性恋
Tasha: Ah, JK sapiosexual.
Tasha: 智性恋
Tasha: Sapiosexual.
Shure: 唱吧唱吧
Shure: Sing, sing.
Shure: 新民主新民主记完了吗
Shure: New democracy, new democracy, did you finish it?
其他人：记好了记好了，
Shure: 还有一个
Shure: There's one more.
Shure: 那个楠楠有两个
Shure: Nan Nan has two.
其他人：就两个
Others: Just two.
其他人：我要贿赂他
Others: I want to bribe him.
其他人：他没给我
Others: He didn't give it to me.
Shure: 主要老板
Shure: Mainly the boss.
Shure: 老板一直盯着我
Shure: The boss keeps staring at me.
Shure: 我这不好不好做事
Shure: It's hard for me to work like this.
Katrina: 哈哈哈老板走了
Katrina: Hahaha, the boss left.
Shure: 来来来你要怎么贿赂我
Shure: Come on, how are you going to bribe me?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 给给给给你3个吧
Shure: I'll give you three, okay?
Shure: 给你凑一下5个吧好吧
Shure: I'll round it up to five for you, alright?
Jake: 好那我们就开始
Jake: Alright, let's get started.
Shure: 好开始先
Shure: Okay, let's start first.
Shure: 是不是房间参观
Shure: Are we touring the room?
Jake: 先先拍吧
Jake: Let's film first.
Shure: 好那就先拍吧
Shure: Okay, let's film first.
Shure: 把
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 这把这一层的任务咱们大家都做完先
Shure: Let's finish the tasks on this floor first.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 那我们进入到了激动人心的auction time
Shure: Now we enter the exciting auction time.
Tasha: 到了激动人心的ocean time
Tasha: It's the exciting ocean time.
Shure: 拍卖时间
Shure: Auction time.
Tasha: 算了你身边是不是没有什么
Tasha: Forget it, don't you have anything?
Shure: 下面有请我们的第一位拍品
Shure: Let's welcome our first auction item.
Shure: 不是那个哎呦我他怎么断了呢
Shure: Wait, why is it broken?
Shure: 老板你干什么的老板
Shure: Boss, what are you doing, boss?
Katrina: 是我们先来是吗
Katrina: Are we going first?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 你先
Katrina: You go first.
Lucia: 啊我吗
Lucia: Ah, me?
Lucia: 他没有灯
Lucia: He doesn't have a light.
Lucia: 而且我的那个欧根纱
Lucia: And my organza...
Lucia: 我发现贴到墙上之后就不好再剪了
Lucia: I found that once it's stuck to the wall, it's hard to cut.
Lucia: 所以我就光这样大概做了一下
Lucia: So I just did it roughly like this.
Katrina: 他的灯在哪贴
Katrina: Where's his light?
Tasha: 身体非常好
Tasha: The body is very good.
Lucia: 理论上说里面应该有一个灯珠
Lucia: There should be a light bulb inside theoretically.
Lucia: 但是他没有
Lucia: But he doesn't have it.
Lucia: 对而且我没有热胶枪
Lucia: Yeah, and I don't have a hot glue gun.
Shure: 来吧第第第一位拍拍卖的同学
Shure: Alright, let's welcome our first auctioneer.
Lucia: 所以这个这个角我是粘住的
Lucia: So, this corner is glued.
Lucia: 但是这个没粘住
Lucia: But this one isn't.
Shure: 来介绍一下自己的拍品
Shure: Go ahead and introduce your item.
Shure: 就路亚同学先来吧
Shure: Let's have Luyya go first.
Lucia: 啊我来吗
Lucia: Oh, should I?
Lucia: 好吧稍等一下
Lucia: Alright, just a moment.
Lucia: 那我就还是用这个小狗吧
Lucia: Then I'll just use this little dog.
Lucia: 如果如果我在接下来的如果
Lucia: If, if in the next, if
Lucia: 我在接下来的5分钟之内
Lucia: in the next five minutes
Lucia: 把那个水母修好了
Lucia: I can fix that jellyfish,
Lucia: 我就我就再我就再来一轮
Lucia: then I will do another round.
Lucia: 就是现在我就只能用这只小狗了
Lucia: But for now, I can only use this little dog.
Lucia: 对它是一个纸箱小狗
Lucia: Yeah, it's a cardboard dog.
Lucia: 然后本来是做好
Lucia: It was originally made
Lucia: 是为了放在我们这个房子的一楼门口
Lucia: to be placed at the entrance of our house.
Lucia: 然后左右各一个就相当于一个石狮子
Lucia: One on each side, like stone lions.
Lucia: 不过它只是一只纸狗
Lucia: But it's just a paper dog.
Lucia: 对然后因为因为我的水母灯
Lucia: Yeah, and because my jellyfish lamp
Lucia: 他因为一些状况他没有灯珠
Lucia: has no lights due to some issues,
Lucia: 并且就是这个腿没有站稳
Lucia: and the legs are unstable,
Lucia: 所以我决定
Lucia: so I decided
Lucia: 先用这个小狗来代替他的位置
Lucia: to use this little dog to replace it for now.
Lucia: 然后如果有喜欢他的朋友们就可
Lucia: If anyone likes it, you can
Lucia: 以尝试出一下价
Lucia: try bidding on it.
Lucia: 好像没有什么其他可介绍的
Lucia: I don't think there's much else to say.
Lucia: 要不先这样哈哈
Lucia: So let's leave it at that, haha.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 呃对
Shure: Uh, yeah.
Shure: 这个路亚同学的这个拍品
Shure: This item from Luyya
Shure: 就是
Shure: is,
Shure: 可能跟我们的这个Eagle life的主题
Shure: kind of related to our Eagle Life theme.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Shure: 比较相关
Shure: It's pretty relevant.
Shure: 就是它是用我们这两天拆的
Shure: It's made from the boxes of packages
Shure: 快递的一些箱子
Shure: we've opened the past few days.
Shure: 做的一些小的手工品
Shure: It's some small handcrafted stuff.
Shure: 还是比较环保比较eco的
Shure: It's quite eco-friendly and sustainable.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Shure: 起拍价
Shure: Starting price
Shure: 一一个一个一个
Shure: One, one, one
Shure: 币子
Shure: 哪位同学好
Shure: Any students interested?
Shure: 我们的小杜出来一个币子
Lucia: 现在开始拍卖了
Lucia: The auction starts now
Shure: 我们的哎
Shure: Our um
Shure: 刚才他他叫什么来着
Shure: What was his name again?
Jake: 黄儿
Jake: Huang
Shure: 王导是吗
Shure: Director Wang, right?
Alice: 黄儿
Alice: Huang
Shure: 黄导是吗
Shure: Director Huang, right?
Jake:小H
Jake: Little H
Shure: 啊黄导出了两个币子
Shure: 还有更高的吗
Shure: Any higher bids?
Shure: 两个币子一次
Shure: Two beats going once
Shure: 两个币子两次
Shure: Two beats going twice
Shure: 两币的三次
Shure: 成交
Shure: Sold
Lucia: 呜
Lucia: Woo
Lucia: 哪哪哪位同学来着
Lucia: Which student was it again?
Shure: 好现在交还你的两个币
Shure: Alright, now hand over your two beats
Jake: 你要记了
Jake: You have to remember
其他人：减两个币那个币给谁了
Others: Deduct two beats, who got the beats?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Shure: 给了路亚
Shure: To Luya
Jake:给LUCIA
Jake: To Lucia
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you
Lucia: 都给我了哈哈哈哈
Lucia: It's all mine, hahaha
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay
Tasha: 好了他的币全部转移了
Tasha: Alright, all his beats have been transferred
Shure: 路亚现在是两个币子
Lucia: 对谢谢
Lucia: Yes, thank you
Lucia: 两个这不刚开始吗哈哈
Lucia: Two, isn't this just the beginning, haha
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two
Alice: 两个
Alice: Two
Shure: 那我们下面有请第2个拍品
Shure: Now let's move on to the second auction item
Lucia: 我去我的压花还没拆突然想起来
Lucia: Oh, I just remembered I haven't unpacked my pressed flowers
Tasha: 接下来拍啥
Tasha: What's up for auction next?
Katrina: 啊这是我们刚开始的时候
Katrina: Ah, this is when we just started.
Katrina: 我给大家每人买了一束鲜花
Katrina: I bought everyone a bouquet of flowers.
Katrina: 然后放花瓶里养
Katrina: Then we put them in vases.
Katrina: 然后买的是那个呃白百合和黄的百合
Katrina: I bought white lilies and yellow lilies.
Katrina: 还有那个康乃馨和芍药
Katrina: Also carnations and peonies.
Katrina: 然后这都是我们自己种的
Katrina: We grew them ourselves.
Katrina: 然后就它慢慢开了以后
Katrina: Once they bloomed,
Katrina: 我们就把它放在那个压花器里面压
Katrina: we put them in a flower press.
Katrina: 然后压两三天以后
Katrina: After two or three days,
Katrina: 晒干以后给大家做成这种书签
Katrina: once they were dried, we made them into bookmarks.
Katrina: 然后就是对就可以放在书里面
Katrina: Then you could put them in books.
Katrina: 然后芍药的话还是挺香的
Katrina: The peonies smell quite nice.
Katrina: 然后还有这种明信片
Katrina: And we also made postcards.
Katrina: 就是明信片的话就是会少一点
Katrina: There are fewer postcards though,
Katrina: 就是放了几片花瓣贴在上面
Katrina: just a few petals glued on them.
Katrina: 然后呃就是长这个样子
Katrina: And they look like this.
Katrina: 然后我这个怎么定价呢
Katrina: How do I price these?
其他人：大家拍一下
Others: Everyone take a shot.
其他人： 起拍价
Others: Starting price.
Katrina: 呃那就是这样
Katrina: Um, so that's it.
Lucia: 呃两个就一ego币起拍
Lucia: Two pieces starting at one ego coin.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 一份明信片加
Shure: One postcard plus
Katrina: 一个书签
Katrina: one bookmark.
Shure: 一个书签
Shure: One bookmark.
Shure: 你这个量有点多
Shure: You have quite a lot here.
Shure: 要不我们重新定一下价呢
Shure: Should we reprice this?
Jake:等会儿吃等会儿吃
Jake: Wait, let's eat later.
Katrina: 0.5个ego币
Katrina: 0.5 ego coin.
Shure: 那我们就是四个
Shure: So we have four pieces.
Shure: 四个来对两
Shure: Four for two.
Shure: 2+2 好吧
Shure: 2+2, okay.
Shure: 两个书签加两个明信片
Shure: Two bookmarks plus two postcards.
Shure: 起拍价一个ego币
Shure: Starting at one ego coin.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two.
Shure: 这个非常吉利啊
Shure: This is very auspicious.
Shure: 两个一次
其他人：三个
Others: Three
Shure: 三个
其他人：她不是有很多组吗，我觉得没必要这样
其他人： 哦哦很多组啊多组啊那得4那得4
Others: Oh, there are many groups, many groups, it should be four, it should be four
其他人：我们一个人一个不就行了吗
Others: Can't we just have one per person?
其他人： 哦哦那得4那得4
Others: Oh, it should be four, it should be four
Shure: 落子无悔啊
Shure: No regrets once you make a move
Shure: 落子无悔我们
Shure: No regrets once we make a move
其他人： 你已经三个了
Shure: 三个一次
Shure: Three at once
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: Three twice
Shure: 三个三次
Shure: Three three times
Jake: 自己人后台无价
Jake: Our own people, priceless backstage
Shure: 成交
Shure: Deal
Shure: 好的我们第一组书签
Shure: Okay, our first group bookmarks
Shure: 家明信片
Shure: Family postcards
其他人： 你先不要着急，我先把钱攒够的
Others: Don't rush, let me save up enough money first
Jake: 还贷款拍卖
Jake: Loan auction
其他人： 我的钱去哪儿了
Others: Where did my money go?
其他人： 这是自己藏的吗
Others: Did you hide it yourself?
其他人：自己藏的自己找是吧
Others: Hiding it yourself and finding it yourself, right?
其他人：私藏钱呢
Others: Stashing money?
其他人：我去找它我藏的
Others: I'll go find what I hid
其他人：我已经散尽家财了
Others: I've already spent all my family fortune
其他人：我只参与了一次成功的拍卖
Others: I only succeeded in one auction
其他人：好我已经散尽家财了
Others: Okay, I've already spent all my family fortune
Shure: 好这是第一组
Shure: Okay, this is the first group
Shure: 第二组起拍
Shure: Starting the second group
Shure: 还有还有两组啊
Shure: There are still two more groups
其他人：一个两个两个三个
Others: One, two, two, three
Shure: 两个三个
Shure: Two, three
Shure: 三个一次三个
Shure: Three once, three
Shure: 两次 3个
Shure: Three twice, three
Shure: 还有没有加价的
Shure: Any more bids?
Shure: 了last time
Shure: Last time
Shure: so
Shure: So
Shure: 是这么喊的吧
Shure: Is this how you call it?
Shure: 好还有最后一组
Shure: Okay, the last group
Shure: 起拍价1 一个两个
Shure: Starting bid 1, one, two
其他人：一个
Others: One
其他人：两个
Others: Two
Shure: 两个一次两个两次哦
Shure: Two once, two twice, oh
Katrina: 我爽了
Katrina: I feel great
Shure: 3个一次还有人要加价吗
Shure: 3 going once, anyone want to raise?
其他人：4个四个
Others: 4, four
Shure: 4个哎呦
Shure: 4, oh wow
Jake: 啊这么有钱
Jake: Ah, so rich
其他人：我有150个
Others: I have 150
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈啊账账本不算啊
Shure: Hahaha, no, the ledger doesn't count
其他人：我有四个啊
Others: I have four
Shure: 啊他他就想想四个来吧
Shure: Ah, he just wants four, come on
Shure: 那四个一次四个两次
Shure: Four going once, four going twice
其他人： 我操没人加价了
Shure: soul四个三次
Shure: Soul, four times
其他人：抬，抬价嘛，抬完就四个了
Katrina: 笑死了好
Katrina: Laughing to death, okay
Katrina: 谢谢老板
Katrina: Thank you, boss
Shure: 记好账啊记好账
Shure: Keep good records, keep good records
Shure: 那剩下这些就一起出来一次
Shure: Then the rest will all come out together once
其他人： 还我吧破产
Others: Give me a break, I'm broke
Shure: 行吧还是你想留留几个
Shure: Alright, do you still want to keep a few?
Tasha: 等我把我的东西卖了我替你还上债
Tasha: Let me sell my stuff and I'll pay off your debt,
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 留着OK好的
Shure: Keep them, okay, fine
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
其他人：你一共几个
Others: How many do you have in total?
Katrina: 我这几个做的不是很好看
Katrina: Mine aren't very well made
Shure: 不是币子
Shure: Not coins
Katrina: 我说我的b吗
Katrina: Are you talking about my b?
Katrina:  我现在是你那4个
Katrina: Now I'm with your four
Katrina: 那是10个OK
Katrina: That's 10, okay
其他人：谢斌竹负4
Others: Thanks, Bin Zhu, minus 4
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:呵呵呵
Alice: Hehehe
Lucia: 你不是150个吗
Lucia: Weren't you at 150?
Katrina: 打几天工吧
Katrina: Gonna work for a few days
Shure: 然后刚刚他们两位的还还是他们两位
Shure: Then just now, still the same for those two
Shure: 他们三位每人是
Shure: Each of the three of them
其他人：我减了3
Others: I deducted 3
Shure: 减了3你减了没
Shure: You deducted 3, did you?
其他人：没没没买没没花出去
Others: No, no, no, didn't buy, didn't spend.
Shure: 还还有谁花了三来着啊他三
Shure: Who else spent 3? Ah, he spent 3.
其他人：还一共多少了哦
Others: How much in total?
其他人：我现在就没了
Others: I have nothing left now.
其他人：我已经没了
Others: I have nothing left.
Shure: 黄导黄导
Shure: Director Huang, Director Huang.
其他人：他你一共多少了
Others: How much do you have in total?
其他人：他说十币
Others: He said 10 coins.
其他人：我没有其他的花销
Others: I have no other expenses.
Shure: 他没变他没变还是九嗯
Shure: He didn't change, he still has 9.
其他人：   这两个也没变
Others: These two didn't change either.
其他人：我们仨都没花出去钱
Others: The three of us didn't spend any money.
其他人： 对呀 这一轮没花出去
Others: Yeah, didn't spend anything this round.
其他人：太可惜了
Others: What a pity.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Shure: 非常可惜
Shure: Very unfortunate.
Shure: 那个请那个场务人员不要哄抬物价啊
Shure: 来吧下一位拍卖者
Shure: Next auctioneer, please.
Shure: welcome any host animal
Shure: Welcome any host animal.
Alice: 我来吧
Alice: I'll go.
Tasha: 不是你刷吗
Tasha: Aren't you going to swipe?
Tasha: 啊刷你先刷
Tasha: Ah, swipe first.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我的我的CP
Lucia: Hahaha, my CP.
Lucia: 我的CP来了
Lucia: My CP is here.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 这是
Shure: This is...
Alice: Lucia的CP狗
Alice: Lucia's CP dog.
Shure: 他叫二狗
Shure: His name is Er Gou.
Alice: Lucia狗的CP狗
Alice: Lucia's dog's CP dog.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈突然打人
Lucia: Hahahahahaha, suddenly hits people.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Alice: 大家可以叫他二哈
Alice: Everyone can call him Er Ha.
Alice: 啊其实我本来准备的是水仙种子
Alice: Actually, I was going to prepare daffodil seeds.
Alice: 但是我P的太狠了
Alice: But I procrastinated too much.
Alice: 我忘买了
Alice: I forgot to buy them.
Alice: 然后就做了一只纸狗
Alice: So I made a paper dog.
Alice: 然后这个纸狗的话赠送一个卫生纸
Alice: And this paper dog comes with a roll of toilet paper.
Alice: 捏的花已经别到他的耳朵上了
Alice: The flower I made is already pinned to his ear.
Alice: 好就这样
Alice: Okay, just like that.
Alice: 起拍价一个
Alice: Starting price is one.
Alice: 大家不用哄抬
Alice: No need to bid it up, everyone.
Alice: 因为我还会捏
Alice: Because I can make more.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 一个起拍
Alice: Starting price is one.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
Shure: 一个一个一次
Shure: One, one, going once.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
其他人：就到此为止吧
Others: Let's stop here.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 一个两次这可比露西亚多一朵花呀
Shure: One, going twice. This is more than Lucia's flower.
Shure: 那我们
Shure: So we...
Tasha: 我帮你还两个啊
Tasha: I'll help you get two.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh, oh.
Tasha: 啊我说哄抬我的
Tasha: I said bid it up.
Tasha: 我的哈哈
Tasha: Mine, haha.
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two.
Jake: 哪来的钱哈
Jake: Where'd you get the money, huh?
其他人：我我我受到蒙骗
Others: I was fooled.
其他人：我退出拍卖了
Others: I'm out of the auction.
其他人：   我退出拍卖
Shure: 那就还是一个
Shure: Then it's still one.
其他人：一个起拍价买到OK
Others: Bought at the starting price, okay.
Shure: SOD
Shure: SOD.
Tasha: 上
Tasha: Go.
Shure: 有没有敲得更响一点的东西
Shure: Is there anything that can make a louder noise?
Alice: 给你留着吧
Alice: Keep it for yourself.
Alice: 你多买点
Alice: Buy more.
Tasha: 你站你去就行
Tasha: You stand, you go.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人： 我来卖东西了
Others: I'm here to sell things.
其他人：你什么时候出来的
Others: When did you come out?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你什么哎
Lucia: What are you... hey?
Tasha: 哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Hahaha!
Lucia: 对哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, haha.
其他人： 我可以和代购
Others: I can do the purchasing.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
其他人：我是代购
Others: I am the buyer.
其他人：这个是我姐做的
Others: My sister made this.
Tasha: 哈哈哈呃
Tasha: Hahaha, ugh.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
其他人：想一下怎么拆
Others: Think about how to unpack it.
Jake: 想一下怎么变
Jake: Think about how to transform it.
其他人： 就这么说吧这个东西从主题上说
Others: Let's put it this way, from a thematic perspective...
其他人：他是一个很环保的种子书签
其他人： 然后你们把这个东西
Others: And then you guys...
其他人： 倒在倒在那个土壤里
Others: Pour it, pour it into the soil.
其他人：浇水太阳能生成种子
Others: Water it, and it will grow seeds with solar energy.
其他人：这是商品的实啊
Others: This is the real deal.
其他人：太阳花上面的实际价值
Others: The actual value of the sunflower on it.
其他人：但是商品的附加价值就非常屌
其他人： 你们买了这个就和我姐建立了联系
Others: When you buy this, you connect with my sister.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
其他人：我姐是个什么人
Others: What kind of person is my sister?
其他人：是一个一晚上让两个男人说话无数次
Others: She can make two men talk non-stop all night.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
其他人： 你们只要认识了她 你们就能一帆风顺
Others: Once you know her, you'll have smooth sailing ahead.
其他人： 起拍价直接从两， 1go 币起拍
其他人：一把吗还是一个
Others: One bundle or one piece?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Shure: 你这不行
Shure: This won't do.
Shure: 市场监督管理局提醒您
Shure: The Market Supervision Bureau reminds you.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Shure: 你这总共有几个
Shure: How many do you have in total?
其他人： 总共6个
Others: A total of six.
Shure: 6个总共6个
Shure: Six, a total of six.
Shure: 两个一个吧
Shure: Two for one, I guess.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 我们不希望东西它不是成对出现的
Shure: We don't want things not to come in pairs.
Shure: 对吧多孤独啊
Shure: Right? That would be so lonely.
其他人：好的，没问题
Shure: 好的那我们1ego币
Shure: 两个种子包
Shure: Two seed packets.
其他人：可以吗
Shure: 起拍
Shure: Starting bid
其他人：2
Others: 2.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人： 走一下流程是吗
Others: So, just going through the process?
Shure: 两个还有更高的吗
Shure: Two, anyone higher?
Shure: 两个一次
其他人：3
Others: 3.
Shure: 哎呦黄导还是大气
Shure: 3个3个一次还有人要加价吗
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: Three, going twice.
Shure: 三个三次成交
Shure: Three, going thrice. Sold.
Shure: 继续
Shure: Let's continue.
Shure: 好的第二轮拍卖
Shure: Alright, second round of auction.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
Shure: 一一个起拍一两个2两个一次
Shure: Starting bid one, two, two going once.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two, going twice.
Shure: 两个3次
Shure: Two, going thrice.
Shure: 成交
Shure: Sold.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：最后一个
Others: The last one.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
其他人：最后一份
Others: The last batch.
Shure: 啊还有最后一份
Shure: Ah, there's one last batch.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure: 两个一次
Shure: Two, going once.
Shure: 还有出更高的吗
Shure: Any higher bids?
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two, going twice.
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 还有还有
Shure: Wait, wait.
Shure: 出价了吗
Shure: Has the bid been placed?
其他人： 三次
Others: Three times.
Tasha: 4个
Tasha: Four.
Shure: 好好四个一次
Shure: Okay, four going once.
Shure: 四个两次
Shure: Four going twice.
Shure: 四个三次成交
Shure: Four going three times, sold.
其他人：爽了姐哈哈哈
Others: Congrats, sis, haha.
Shure: OK我们host auction部分还有
Shure: OK, we still have items for the host auction.
Shure: 大家要拍卖物品吗
Shure: Does anyone want to auction items?
Lucia: 我现在下去做去哈哈
Lucia: I'll go down and prepare, haha.
Shure: okay好的
Shure: Okay, sure.
Lucia: 真的我想起来我那没拆
Lucia: Really, I just remembered I have some unopened stuff.
Shure: 那
Shure: Then...
Lucia: 大家先玩着
Lucia: You guys go ahead and play first.
Shure: 那现在没有了这个host auction的部分
Shure: Alright, that's it for the host auction part for now.
Shure: 然后我们现在进入到下一part
Shure: 没有没有也
Shure: No, no, not at all.
Shure: 那个可以不介绍
Shure: That part doesn't need an introduction.
Shure: 可以给大家讲个笑话讲个故事
Shure: How about I tell you guys a joke or a story?
Shure: 都可以就是只要你上台来我就会
Shure: Anything goes, as long as you come on stage, I will...
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone...
Shure: 评委席就会根据表现来给各位打分
Shure: The judges will score you based on your performance.
Shure: 并且发放一个币
Shure: And you'll get a token.
Shure: 有自告奋勇的吗
Shure: Any volunteers?